let's do this bye-bye cases first okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
say just like before when there you see
the absolute value of anything it means
two things at the same time depending on
what your values of exile so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say I'm
going to name them I'm going to say
there's a case where X is negative and
therefore that absolute value will be
this and then there's a case where we're
not X the whole thing in here is
positive and that's a different thing so
case one is where X plus 1 on X is doing
a positive Christmas okay so if this is
true which by the way I don't know when
that is true I'll find out in a minute
but it's whatever is inside the brackets
whenever that is true the absolute value
of that is just that I've donated to a
planet - sighs - it so let me write that
out X plus 1 on X is less than 2x and I
have to try and solve this thing ok now
there's another case case do which is
where X plus 1 of X is not greater than
0 it's where it's negative ok
and in that case the absolute value of
blah blah blah blah is not just that I
have to apply my innocence of the whole
thing okay so it's going like this how
are you travelling so far all I've done
is I've broken apart
according to its positive negative miss
I do also want to point out just like
the very first question we did this
morning
do you notice I don't have greater than
or equal to you and I don't have less
than or equal to you tell me why say
again
ya see that it's there right that one
there
it means I'm divided by X so X can never
be 0 ok so therefore cool I'm not now
here's the tricky thing
I am I don't actually know when this is
the case it's not as simple as this guy
this guy over here which is like I know
exactly when that's right in zero it's
when X is positive or X is negative here
because there are these two things that
are interacting with each other I'm not
sure what's going on so I'm going to
have to think carefully about that in a
second before I start to like work with
this question I need to look at a
simpler version okay so if I said to you
hmm
if I said to you something simple like
this let's go ahead and we can actually
just solve this really simply what can I
do to get to my solution what would be a
first step that would simplify this a
little bit yeah I'll add 5 to both sides
and then I'm going to divide by 2 which
gives me this and then I can draw that
if I need to or all that kind of thing
now what I want to point out is yes I'm
just going to I'm just going to draw it
if that's 0 if that's to have this
hollow circle and I'm going all the way
that way this inequality represents a
whole bunch of values over here an
infinite set of values however it has
like a starting point it starts here and
then it goes and goes and goes that
starting point like where does it start
starting point
can be found by solving the equation
that matches this equality okay so if I
solve this inequality Oceanside so if I
solve this solving this is not the same
as solving this but it tells me where
this is going to start because I do
exactly the same thing da-da-da-da-dah
and I end up with x equals 2 and 1/2
right so if I solve the equation the fan
I'll be able to find where it starts and
then I just work out am I on the left or
am I on the right ok um if for example
the question was not this if the
question had the employer facing the
other way less than less then do you
notice the equation can't tell which way
you're facing right
the equation only tells you where do you
start it tells you at that point and
then you kind of have to work out
whether you're in that way or do you go
that way and you look back at the
inequality to tone I'm going to take
advantage of the same trick over here I
want to work out what the starting point
is and the reason why I go in that
direction is how do I solve this thing
what do I do with it
okay this one on X is a bit problematic
I don't encounter equations like this
that makes an X and a dividing by X the
same times why do you have a lot of
experience with is quadratic functions
but to turn this into a quadratic I have
to multiply through if I multiply
through by X right
what does that turn the left-hand
silencer last one if I multiply the
right-hand side by X I get 2x squared
degree but now I'm in a bit of a dilemma
because when you're dealing with
inequalities correct when you multiply
by a number the inequalities Direction
can change depending on what the number
is so if X is negative the inner corner
will change and if X is positive the
inequality will not change but I don't
know what it is right yeah
I mean you would because if you do our
times if I minus 1 if I'm up I'm a
negative 1 I would know what's happening
but the problem is like X can be
negative 1 or it could be other stuff
too and I don't know right so I'm a bit
stuck so therefore I'm like ok so let's
find a starting point and then we'll
look left and right ok now I'm going to
do this so if I say I'm going to solve
this now so what I'm going to do is I
want to find like where do you begin and
then I'll look into it okay so I'm going
to do the same thing I did before x
squared plus 1 equals 2x squared I can
multiply through by X that's fine
because I have to worry about a
direction here I can help me solve this
thing yeah so if I subtract 2x squared
from both sides that we needed makes a
real +10 and of course that's a bit of a
weird way to write that so we'll just
fix that up so that looks like this yes
so what this means is see this thing
it's true somewhere where is it true
well the places where it's going to
start from a plus and minus 1 okay
so on one side of 1 and on the other
side one on one side maybe one what's up
pop with the other side negative 1 I'm
gonna find out where it's true or not
okay now I'm just going to stop for a
second this is really hard what we're
doing this is quite confusing I actually
don't even know the answer at this point
because I can't visualize what is
happening like when is this true I don't
really know okay in fact over here you
know how I said case 1 case 2 if I
followed this direction like multiply
through by X and deal with the
inequality just watch I wouldn't have to
do more cases I don't have to say
there's another case there's case this
is case 1 so I'm going to call this case
1 Fe if X is greater than 0
right and I multiply through by X what
happens to see the inequality so does it
change it as a state it states so this
will become x squared plus 1 is the same
as 2 x squared so I can solve this now
this is going to become like we saw
before 1 minus x squared it's less than
zero and then I'm gonna have to solve
that but that might not be the case this
is another case this case 1 B where X is
less than 0 and the inequality changes
direction right so it's gonna look like
this whew
x squared plus 1 is greater than 2x
where you see it change direction there
and so I'm gonna subtract this and then
I'm gonna have to solve that now I'm
confused I have so many inequalities
flying around in like what is X what can
it be what can it not be
and I don't absolutely know and this is
the classic reason why cases will work I
promise you if I do this all correctly I
will get the right answers at the bottom
so there's no flaw in the method it's
just confusing right I don't know I
still don't know what direction I'm
headed it usually because I've been
taking this for ages by the time I get
about half or two-thirds the way through
the question I can start to see oh
that's what the answer will be I don't
know I do yeah yeah so there are four
cases ok because the four cases come
from two parts the first case comes from
hey you got any value here right and
then the number of cases doubles because
it's an inequality and you have to be
like well is it gonna go that way or
that way so this is why it's so
confusing okay so I'm gonna keep pause
on that and I'm gonna show you how I
would do it visually okay so I'm going
to draw this and I want anyone try and
keep track with me and draw it along
with me myself
yeah that's right
I'm gonna restart because you know what
I'm not even halfway on my solution is
question because having a started on
this guy and then I'm gonna and this
guy's not finished yet so yeah I like I
said cases can work in very simple
examples which is why people are gonna
start with that but the simple examples
kind of get left behind and they're like
hey